so you're vacationing in Zambia huh
mm-hmm let me guess you're from LA New
York yes I take it mr. Conrad won't be
joining us two days ago he told me that
our marriage was over
Oh two hours ago I landed here on what
was supposed to be our second honeymoon
yeah by myself a lot of people come here
to get lost so they can be found again
thank you Yoda oh you're coming on this
too
yep Tara Collinsworth in case you want
to write my name down on a complaint
form
oh yeah the pilot we're flying over the
largest game reserve in Africa hang on
I'm gonna make a stop stay in the plane
hook come back
[Music]
poachers kill the mom of her tusks we
don't do something to help that baby we
built in two days I want to help didn't
see that one coming house first well I
took a little detour it's gonna be okay
it'll be touch and go for a while but we
will do our best
I'm in this place surrounded by wild
animals hey New York oh sorry
um we are coming home right this year
it's gonna be Christmas in Africa what
is Christmas in Africa well I can't
speak for the whole continent but here
at the elephant orphanage they celebrate
all week and there's no shopping
involved I'm really starting to worry
I've got to go back home and I don't
know what I'm supposed to do with myself
maybe you're doing it here this is how
it starts we meet an elephant and so
begins the relationship of a lifetime
take good care of my elephant he and I
were just friends mmm-hmm since you
didn't get to go in your fancy five-star
Safari let me take you on one with a
little stress like three thinking more
like two I haven't seen you hit someone
in in a long time if I've learned
anything it's to not get too attached
never meant to stay this long you're
falling in love huh
with Africa you know what that is what
this hotel that is definitely not no
South African mistletoe
[Music]
you